e aí galera que este campeonato pra você
e eu estou delícia como sempre o meu
quarto totalmente enfeitado namorada
rízia grande bela surpresa para mim e
minha namorada muito 5 182 fazer
brincadeirinha que vamos fazer e vou
ligar para minha mãe e dizer que você
papai
meu deus do céu eu mantenho meu celular
que estava tomado como sempre estava
sozinho na tomada ela fazia tanto tempo
carregando já perdendo de boca e ter de
tomar vamos ligar então também fosse
proibida pela anac e à caixa de
mensagens
liguei muito sala dela e chamou e
admirou eu acho que ela vai retornar pra
mim vamos ver só retorna na parte norte
sabe mãe atualizada é o súbito do
catálogo unido nero nox ato vai demorar
é assim tão sério
criou e agora foi o que a senhora que em
casa
o senhor sabe que eu viajei combina que
a gema é com ela pra bahia pa
gramado
tô bem nós vamos pô ela começa a sentir
as coisas ruins a gente vai fazer um
teste mas agrada é o único de mãe mas se
cuida
a casa dela foi encontrado pela manhã
foi diz que vai contar com o padrão
e agora senão na costa da paróquia do
monte foi minha casa não fica tem casa
mas no futebol nem marcos ficar igual em
macaé deixou fica a mina embora agora
mandou ela mandou a mensagem que o pai
dela diz que é para amanhã a casa
e assim essa arrogância ea senhora vai
ser vovô agora sei que antes de fazer o
gol que deu errado eo que deu errado de
casa agora eu tenho o texto como chegar
lá você vai dar não vai fazer porque é
bem maior que o mesmo tem uma amiga que
tenho é a vida corrida então para cá tem
nada nem um cachorro não sabia nadar
eu tenho que botar um tempo que a gente
não está pensando em fazer outro está
pensando em fazê lo quando menino eu
acho que tem hoje
é brincadeira onde esse povo a mãe agora
só poderá viajar a senhora um feliz dia
das mulheres
tá bom né mas eu vou postar no dia 8 um
filho das mulheres com a senhora com a
todas as mulheres de bom jesus quando a
gente mora toda mulher do piauí e do
brasil do ceará de todo mundo tá e
principalmente na china a hora que é o
da mulher mais batalhador que eu a vi na
minha vida
saudade de bode
tá bom
um beijo tchau
eu queria aproveitar e mandar um
parabéns a todas as mulheres nesse mundo
é ciumenta é tem depende tem a gente não
vive se você e parabéns à minha mãe para
ver se a minha volta parabéns à minha
namorada para ver o tamanho da minha
namorada e parabéns para a mãe de vocês
que está assistindo agora parabéns pra
você que a mulher também assiste agora é
também que tem 11 anos nem desde o
permitido às mulheres pra mim sai daí
louca que não tem nenhum efeito se você
vai gostar do videoclipe gostei está no
facebook clique em curtir tá no twitter
clique rtp vai me ajudar muito curta
forte divulgação instagram
muito obrigado é de natal no rio grande
do norte 17 e dia 8 é o dia
internacional da mulher vai ter show em
natal tá ingressos no é de céu
tecnologia no praia shopping e dia 13 eu
voltar em caruaru um teatro difusora e
dia 14 está em recife no teatro boa
vista todas as informações a descrição
do vídeo só foi cair bem e é nós valeu
muito obrigado
até mais